Hello? If anyone's in here, the police are on
their way-
Ow! Ow, Ow, Ow, Ow!
Nom!
What? Why are you staring at me like that?
I thought you were dead. I saw the Duke throw
you down the boo-hoo hole.
I was lucky. The walls were jagged with pieces of
Lego. They snagged me, broke my fall,
but hurt the whole way down.
Well, it looks like we're matches, huh?
Red Vines.
Twizzlers. Pull and peel.
This is from a supply raid.
And.
Uh, are we just going to leave the pupa behind, Terry?
He can't get out of the pupa seat. And even
if he could, he'd never stray from his puffs.
Ah.
The cow says.
Eddie. Oh, you're home early.
Katie.
Baby, kiss me.
Oh.
Get in here.
Still can't believe it was one year ago to
the day you got down on your knee and gave
this to me. Remember? It was our second date.
I thought you were crazy.
I am crazy for you.
I swore I would never go out with someone who
worked for my dad. But you're not like his
other employees. You're. You're different.
Oh. How'd the sales trip go?
Crushed it. Crushed it.
Daddy will love that.
Means he won't see it coming when we rob him
blind.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Hup!
Hup! Hup! Hup! Ah, I hate doing this because
I'm the cool one who bites the cheese right off
the block instead of cutting off a piece. But
you leave me no choice. No more iPad, no more
sexy books. No more Hulu.
Look at him. He's learning his lesson so hard
right now. Maybe I am the pupa expert.
I did not know that was an option.
Aww, he laid an apology egg.
Apology egg-cepted, Pupa!
Yeah Buddy!
What the hell is that?
Little buddy!
Yeah, buddy!
Hahaha Yeah Buddy!
How the hell am I supposed to punish him when
he's palling around with a little buddy?
Oh shit. If we had just smashed Pupa's head
with a hammer and thrown him in the quarry,
none of this would have happened.
This is the time of year where we are
compelled to gather and celebrate the light
of our Lord and Savior, Jesus Christ. Thank
you all for rejecting the commercialization
of the holiday. Only here in the House of God
can your spirits truly be blessed.
Amen. Oh.
Sorry to interrupt the service. I just. I've
made a horrible mistake. My son came out as a
tiny bit bi last week, and I kicked him out
of the house. I've ruined our lives. I miss
him so much.